paint me like one of your french girls
today we are painting naked portraits of
each other I'm so excited I think it
should make it fortune when you start
getting comfortable with someone then
you kind of start letting things go and
we were just like new
we hate clothes I'm for sure more
worried about painting than I am getting
naked I haven't painted a long time so
yeah that drawing is I'm not gonna like
paint ABS on you not very good at this
not very good at what you're really good
at being naked so you got that part down
I can draw a penis out of frosting in a
piping bag to put on like a cookie or
cake so that might be the only part that
looks humid can we turn the heater on a
little bit yeah yeah there she is
Oh hot baby that's like really
concentrate on this painting that talks
you naked I feel like a five-year-old
first thought you got man arms now so I
apologize for that it's like it's the
first time I've ever seen a penis this
is fun seriously we do to make this an
activity I completely budget this no
definitely not
I'm about to do your boobs your favorite
I'm hanging this in our bathroom I'm
serious
Stacey No so your hands may look a
little smaller than they actually are
can you just lay like this like a chalk
outline hang of a dead body oh my god
these proportions are so awful is it
growing
yeah there's only one thing you got a
proportion right it's getting don't
think I've like done watercolors since I
was like probably watercolor paint the
pain I paint the penis well there's a
water cat pose it's got a rinse cup can
we just like reflect on the phrase paint
the penis what's the dude that place
the guy is friend in The Big Lebowski
don't be offended by your pants John
Goodman you look like John Goodman
oh you've called flour frame my favorite
part about this it's doing you little
features very detailed you have the nibs
yeah my hair I'm gonna turn it around
and it's just gonna be a circle it's a
different color
no it's most focused on the couch this
is like monkey arms for sure is that
cookies and cream yeah hmm
my breasts look great you know I'm gonna
oh hi yeah they do
Oh check that out look at that size and
the thigh muscle damn I don't even work
out the legs definitely makes me feel
like we can just pretty much do anything
in front of each other and not only the
being naked in front of each other bar
cuz that's one thing that happens all
the time I think the main thing is to
try and do something like this every day
even just saying something that was like
his whole world and that's what he
thinks I am to him oh hey yeah oh [ __ ]
this tells a story of sadness
[Music]